Russia has released 215 Ukrainian
prisoners of war in a deal negotiated by
turkey
Ukraine says among them are 108 members
of the so-called as of Battalion they
had surrendered to Russian forces in the
city of maripole back in May after
putting up resistance while holed up
inside the as of style steelworks along
with their families
in return Kiev has freed pro-russian
oligarch Victor Medved joke and 854
Russian prisoners
in a separate deal negotiated by Saudi
Arabia 10 foreigners who fought for
Ukraine have been freed by Russia and
sent to Riyadh among them is Ada naslin
a British citizen sentenced to death by
russian-backed separatists
Dave duroche is a senior fellow at the
gulf International Forum he explains the
significance of this prisoner swap
both sides have a lot of incentive to do
this to exchange prisoners
Moscow clearly wants a situation where
um it's pres its soldiers taking
prisoners are not tried for war crimes
even if they've committed them and what
they've done to kind of put leverage on
the Ukrainian side is they generally
announce that prisoners are held not by
Moscow but by the two puppet States
they've set up in the dawn bass that
would also Force other intermediers to
deal with these countries or with these
provinces as if they were countries
um
the same time you know the the presence
of foreign prisoners being released uh
Moscow and moscow's two puppets have
threatened to try them as uh war
criminals just because you know they're
not ukrainians
um so it's it's a very very complicated
issue and I'm not sure if the timing is
as significant as as we might think it
is but of course you have the UN General
Assembly going together uh Saudi Arabia
and uh turkey uh seem to have a new era
of cooperation there's discussion of uh
joint production of drones for example
but I think it's basically designed to
get positive buzz and to enhance the
status of both countries that have uh
feel that they're not getting the
respect they deserve in the west at a
time when all the leaders of the world
are together in New York